but let me start with grief we have
achieved significant progress on the
second review since the last Eurogroup
in March as you remembered then on my
initiative we changed the strategy we
changed the order of things and we
intensified talks to first of all reach
a agreement between the institutions and
Greek government on the key elements the
overarching elements of the policy
package we have an agreement on these
overarching elements of policy in terms
of size timing and sequencing of the
reforms and on that basis further work
will continue in the coming days I'm
quite convinced that the time is ripe to
bring an end to uncertainty has been
umber denying the Greek economy for so
long on Cyprus the economic situation
remains positive grows picked up last
year and is expected to remain strong in
2017 Cyprus still needs to pursue
prudent fiscal policies and the current
bright economic climate should make that
easier the ongoing expansion in the
eurozone is firming will continue to
firm and broaden in the eurozone and we
see the pass through a fair amount I
policy measures supporting domestic
demand including investments the
conclusion is that further business
friendly reforms remain necessary to
strengthen the recovery I thought it was
very important that the Eurogroup today
discuss two issues how to strengthen
investments the second one we ought
reports on the functioning of the
banking Union in a longer-term context
this is actually I think more important
than solving specific country related
problems